let's get reaction now from Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter she's president
of security studies the security studies
group and Jim Hanson military analysts
and retired colonel Douglas McGregor
alright guys a lot to unpack here Sarah
let's start with you
what is your take tonight I mean the
goal here is to provide a strong
deterrence against the production spread
in use of chemical weapons we tried to
do that last year was it done
successfully last year apparently not
but this will this is a difficult
situation because obviously Syrian
President Bashar al Assad since he first
launched chemical attacks in 2013 in
Gouda and I remember being on the phone
with doctors actually I was talking to a
doctor in Gouda when the attack was
launched and I remember the horror that
that they were facing then so there we
haven't seen it as a deterrent since
that I mean Assad's continued to use
this but now we see three nations
joining together France Great Britain in
the United States sending a strong
message not just to Assad but to Russia
and Iran in to the rest of the world as
well as North Korea remember
proliferation is what we're really
concerned about here if we're concerned
about our national security risk then
this is the reason why the president did
this he was standing on the principle
that he told them if you cross this red
line with me I have to react and
eventually he did so we're gonna have to
wait and see how this unfolds because we
don't know what Russia's reactions going
to be to this I know a lot of people are
concerned but you know what bullies are
bullies and when you push a bully back
most of the time they back up what we
still don't know Colonel McGregor well I
find the whole thing
perplexing I mean first of all just a
week after the president announces his
intention to withdraw troops from Syria
suddenly the Syrian government that is
effectively won the civil war the Civil
War is practically over decides to
launch a chemical attack seems very odd
then we see sarin and chlorine gas used
together that's never happened before
that's the first in the history of
chemical warfare doesn't make any sense
then finally we said well we didn't
really inform the Russians but we know
the German press has told us over the
last 24 hours of consistent
back-channel reports between Washington
and and Moscow so I'm quite quite
obvious that we made the Russians aware
what was going on they got out of the
way and we picked targets that I think
in retrospect will turn out perhaps not
to be what we thought so I think this is
another cosmetic attack that makes the
morally righteous in Washington feel
good but changes nothing on the ground
Jim
South Sudan has had a four-year civil
war that's killed tens of thousands of
people entire villages have been burned
with flamethrowers boys and girls locked
in straw huts lit on fire
there are atrocities committed every day
all over the world including in our
strategic adversary China and yet we go
in again with a military strike a year
after a previous military strike and I
guess it feels good because they're
horrible things happening there but what
do we really accomplish here tonight in
Syria this was not why Donald Trump got
elected in my view but president Trump
delivered a warning and President
Vladimir Putin Assad and the Iranians
all ignored that warning he delivered on
the promise that he would retaliate if
they did he had to do that and and it
was the right thing to do we also have a
strategic interest in Iran not becoming
a land bridge to the Mediterranean
it's a bigger story but what President
Trump did here is he delivered the
correct message to the correct parties
what was blown up it's important but
it's not the most intact thing the fact
that we will deliver on our promises as
the United States and I thought as Sarah
said I thought it was great then we put
the band back together and that the US
the UK and France acted in concert that
matters to the world to show that we are
now a coalition of some of the strongest
countries that Hsieh Crescent from
developing and and that's something else
that they're very concerned about is how
Iran is moving across the Middle East
and who started I mean I just cover and
how did that start I mean there's a lot
of dominoes falling in the Middle East
and sometimes what it feels good in the
moment the Iraq war which I was all in
favor of then all of a sudden you look
at for years ladies like what the heck
do what the hell what's Isis what
we get out matters yeah how we the I'm
game in Syria matters I still don't know
Sebastian you're so smart
why does Saddam Hussein Osama saying I
see him have it all confused why did
Assad decide to do this now Sebastian
given the fact that Donald Trump his
instinct is let's get the heck out of
there
we've trillions of dollars spent in the
Middle East China is on the rise we
don't want to get bogged down there and
then the attack happens why did that
unfold that way look Laura I know a lot
of people are queasy tonight but they
should look Colonel McGregor's being
obnoxiously obtuse the president needs
to be listened to
this isn't about Rwanda this isn't about
Sudan this is a battlefield where
chemical weapons are on the loose with
multiple actors many of them jihadists
this is a regime that has committed mass
murder his father was a mass murderer
and so is Bashar al-assad the idea that
this is irrelevant to America is so a
strategic it beggars belief the
president is not an interventionist he's
not going to deploy a hundred and sixty
thousand troops like the Bush
administration did but we have to assert
our moral clarity you do not get to use
illegal chemical weapons against women
and children and I was in the White
House a year ago and I saw the
intelligence and guess what colonel it
was the Assad regime that did it and
when a four-star retired Marine Corps
legend like the current Secretary of
Defense tells you that we've seen the
intelligence and it was Assad everybody
should take that to the bank and shame
on you for questioning general mattis
retired well I've met general mattis and
I'm happy to question it because I don't
think general mattis meant what he said
you don't have the clearances and you
haven't seen it colonel
well you'd be surprised at the
clearances that I have have you seen
intelligence
have you seen intelligence Sebastian
will you please calm down for a second
no it's outrageous we've been we've been
down this road before we launched
kruseman's not with this present
99 again not with this president a lot
of time Sebastian you can respond in one
second we launched we launched it
against the factory service building
missile parts in 1999 and connected to
al-qaeda it was a milk production
facility we've had so much
misinformation it is absolutely not
clear what happened a year ago
I completely read it is to me you were
outside the building here to meet
absolutely not and I have spent my life
in the military and I have seen
intelligence manipulated repeatedly over
the last 25 20 some glad you know better
than this president that Secretary of
Defense think that President Trump needs
to listen to the 50 million Americans
who voted for him there was 60 actually
and they didn't support this I'm glad
you speak to all Americans colonel I'm
glad you've made yourself the spokesman
of 60 million Americans that's a very
modest of you well let's talk about the
War Powers Resolution because that this
always comes up every time we launch a
military strike whether Congress should
give its imprimatur to the action and it
allows the President to use force in an
attempt he can do it on his own doesn't
have to go to Congress very limited
narrow criteria many say tonight that
didn't meet that criteria that this type
of strike actually does require
congressional approval I understand I
can actually make the argument from both
sides I think it's an interesting
discussion
Jim the War Powers Act has never been
tested in the Supreme Court so there's
no ruling as to whether it's a god the
Supreme Court gets most of most of the
stuff from Constitution under Article 2
as general mattis cited gives the
president authority as
commander-in-chief to do what he needs
to do to take care of Americans
strategic interests worldwide anytime
anyplace anywhere if he thinks the
Syrian regime dropping chemical weapons
in a theater where there are US troops
on the ground is important enough to
bomb them he's got every right and he
doesn't have to ask anybody Jim just
brought up a really important point we
do have troops on the ground we are
still continuing to train people are
still losing their lives in this region
and they're fighting back against not
just Assad but Iranian IRGC on the
ground we know that they're watching the
Russians we also have Intel
assets on the ground so when something
like this happens when we're in direct
threat and I think not just to our men
and women on the ground but also to our
nation I mean we have to think of the
national security implications of
proliferation and that's something that
a lot of people are not thinking about
but we had Islamic state on the ground
we have Al Qaeda we have various rebel
group did a Sode attack Isis what we did
we did a side attack Isis you mean did a
side attack Isis I heard a number of
things though not only was Assad yeah I
heard of McCain was going to like give
the good rebels I never never worked out
so right at the very beginning the Free
Syrian Army was being promised by the
Obama administration that we're gonna
help supply you when that didn't happen
you saw factions and divisions among the
ground it's a wild place I mean look a
rack was a wild place I mean I remember
being there in 2006 I was like that's
not exactly the way I thought it would
be it's just it's a wild place that very
few Americans understand Syria and
Sebastian you know this is also it is
incredibly complex there are so many
different ethnic and tribal conflicts on
Isis offshoots that they fight among
each other they're not even on the same
side and then of course Assad with his
murderous tactics why didn't Germany
join us in this effort tonight the
biggest economy in the EU such a
critical ally of the United States
Sebastian where was Angela Merkel the
same Germany that told its ambassador in
NATO that he is banned from using the
word counterinsurgency when discussing
NATO operations in Afghanistan and it's
just a humanitarian operation that paper
tiger look I have to comment on what
Sarah says she's absolutely right and
what Jim is saying think of one thing
everybody out there who's got issues
everybody who's got their tinfoil hat on
that the white helmets did it and Russia
said the British did the chemical attack
I mean do you want to believe that one
next to anybody who has doubts think
about this one question what happens
when the Assad regime uses chemical
weapons as secretary mattis said and as
he did last year and I saw the
intelligence
for the proof of that being the Assad
regime and we do nothing what message
does that send to Iran what message does
that send to Assad what message was that
sent to proxies because it sends a clear
message as far as I'm concerned that we
got away with it and we can do it again
and what are they going to do it next in
Jordan one of our most important allies
in the region to precipitate a civil war
there are they going to do it in Tel
Aviv are we prepared to let that genie
out of the bottle I as an American as a
taxpayer
as somebody who believes that these
kinds of weapons are illegal and should
be responded to I'm not prepared to pay
that price I understand everything
you're saying Sebastian but my question
is a simple one we hear a lot about the
international community the
international community this the
international community we're doing it
for international norms it's the worst
thing ever of course
it's horrific to use any type of
chemical weapon nerve agent it's beyond
beyond we can't that we came to
comprehend it as Americans so where is
the world community it's great we have
brainwork France I love it but the world
community without without without
American leadership that there is no
actual heroes money we're out of money
we have no dough it's not 1995 anymore
so we don't so we let children go I'm
not saying that but if we what's a poor
country that is desperately in debt and
getting weaker and weaker and weaker
according to our debt year after year
after year at some point somebody's
gonna have to pay the piper wrong here
we got like blocks of people living out
on the street many of them what's that
got to do with national security but if
we're if we are a broke nation at some
point the American people forget about
what we say on this panel tonight I'm
playing devil's advocate here because at
some point the American people are gonna
say you know something I'm not voting
for this anymore they're gonna elect
like Elizabeth Warren folks that's what
I'm worried about that's the most I'm
worried about president asked for oh
myyy out all right he said I want to
leave Syria all right we gave the plan
to the National Security Council for a
way for the regional allies to start
taking over that four
Saudi Arabia to pay some of the freight
for the other dolt where eliminations
they don't have the capability to do
this right now in the relationship
between Saudi Arabia and Israel and I
can tell you talking to sources in
Israel talking to sources in Saudi
Arabia there has been a big difference
and I think that shift is important
because what Saudi Arabia is most
concerned about is Iran and Saudi
Arabia's willing is willing to make
amends with Israel to some extent even
offer their Ariel Sharon their
neighborhood Jared Kushner has actually
done great work on that and gets no
credit he's done great work which you're
going to hear a lot more about in the
next coming weeks McGregor look I think
your viewers should understand that
Congress is a rubber stamp it's not
doing its job and hasn't done its job
for decades it's very comfortable
sitting there and essentially turning
everything over to the president until
something really bad happens at which
point in time of course they will blame
whoever is in the White House secondly
again this is a facade this is designed
to look like something it's nothing the
ground what we hit on the ground tonight
is meaningless
how do you know that well not because
look the targets it count were the
Russian targets without Russia Assad
would not exist without Russia Assad
would not have become at Russian troops
in troops Russian Air Force Russian air
defenses Russian missiles Iran as well
Iranian troops they are the critical
factor in the victory in Syria now they
are going to divide that country it's
over we are not going to shape the
distance the Russia and Iran are going
to divide up but I also think that we
were strategic in how we did this right
because if we target the Russians on the
ground in Syria if we target Iran
specifically we could end up escalating
this to a point oh yeah yeah thank you
turn right right not be disaster but
Santa Sebastian last word just listen to
what the president said he said very
clearly we are not there to do some kind
of intervention like in the Gulf War
back in 2003 we are there to make a
stand
one of the most heinous forms of weapons
known to man that are illegal and
America as a brand if we do nothing then
America as a nation starts to lose its
meaning for what it represents I know
you believe in what that nation
represents you're a believer you believe
in the eternal values that our founding
fathers instilled in our founding
documents if those documents mean
anything today we take this action yeah
I think I think you'll get all pullout
quotes about from the framers about this
Godfather Laura but Sebastian don't
think it on your moral high or something
no like no don't don't don't play that
you're making it like a joke a joke
you're raising the flag of the framers I
can quote and Alexander Hamilton at a
George Washington you tonight where
they're warning of chemical weapons got
entangled in foreign and foreign affairs
all I'm saying is I'm not saying it's
applicable necessarily here but we can't
you know what gives out the framers I
mean it's a complicated situation